s'agissant de la doctrine d'accueil
c'est à dire la traduction concrète de
ce que l'on met derrière l'expression
progressivité
il y a d'une part le la question de qui
rentre comment au travail et ensuite à
quel rythme non s'agissant des les
élèves
l'idée est donc actuellement et bien
entendu sur réserve de tout ce que l'on
pourra disputer encore pour des temps
proches comme une idée actuellement est
d'abord qu'il ya un impératif
catégorique qui est liée à la doctrine
sanitaire dans un haut-parleur et
ensuite quiconque travaille par deux
types définiront auquel et le plafond de
ces petits bouts sera peut-être
différent pour l'école primaire et pour
l'enseignement secondaire mais un mais
se plaint qu'on pourrait par exemple de
15 élèves et n'y aurait donc pas une
seule classe tu devrais plus de 15
élèves pendant cette période ce qui très
souvent ne reviendra qu'en un demi
groupe avec une classe existantes
cela signifierait que nous faire une
rentrée à partir du de la semaine du 11
mai et réalité ce ne serait pas le 11
mai lui-même ce qu'il y aurait une pré
rentrée des professeurs de l'école
primaire
mais au cours des jours suivants nous
ferions rentrée les classes de grande
section de cp et de cm2 ou laisserions
démarche de souplesse importante
localement pour définir ensuite le fait
de savoir si la manière de faire des
demi groupe en particulier ce qui est
certainement
toutes les façons de au moins de 15 et
les donc pourront rentrer sans grande
modification
les cp et ce1 de répérer de plus je
rappelle que ça représente 290 1000
élèves
aujourd'hui donc on a eu pour rentrer 17
cette semaine a de même tous les élèves
d'écoles primaires des écoles de où il
ya des classes avec moins de quinze
élèves c'est à dire en milieu rural ça
représente 65 mille enfants aujourd'hui
pourront rentrer aussi cette semaine a
de manière normale je dirais puisqu'ils
ont le taux d'encadrement qui convient
ensuite on aurait l'enseignement
secondaire en semaine 2 c'est-à-dire la
semaine qui commence le 18 mai avec le
collège pour lesquelles ce serait la
classe de 6ème et la classe de 3e puis
ainsi que le lycée la classe de 1ère et
la classe de terminale il ya enfin le
lycée professionnel pour lesquels on
commencerait par les ateliers
industriels et enfin en semaine 3 le 25
mais bien l'ensemble des classes
pourrait rentrer mais le système serait
organisé pour que ce soit toujours et
des groupes de pas plus de quinze élèves
pour y arriver